good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
1013 object class
CER special containment procedures
standard safety procedures for visually
reactive items ed8 are to be posted at
all times any staff entering the
containment area are to review this
document before entering any staff
entering the containment area are to
wear the AR 68 armored variant hazmat
suit staff exiting the area with damaged
suits are to be remanded to quarantine
for 1 hour staff becoming paralyzed
during cleaning feeding or testing
Cycles are to be immediately removed and
remanded to Medical custody until 5
hours after recovery SCP 10113 is to be
fed once daily consisting of one small
mammal for example rabbit large rat cat
or dog this feeding is only to take
place if there are no calcified remains
still within the containment area
calcified remains that are no longer
actively being fed upon are to be
removed and disposed of via incineration
Hazmat Protocols are to be observed
during the disposal process test subject
remains may be taken into the
containment area for feeding purposes
only when standard feeding practice
cannot be observed staff succumbing to
SCP 1013 prefeeding effects are to be
removed and disposed of all remains must
be disposed of within 1 hour of final
calcification description SCP 1013
appears to be a small reptile with a
distinctly Aven head a wide frail
extends from the base of of the head and
can be flared out via bony spines
radiating through the frill from the
neck the body appears similar to most
common reptiles with the exception of
the head and abnormally long tail while
the main body is only 60 cm long the
tail is nearly 121 cm and exceptionally
flexible SCP 1013 has been observed to
use this tail to trip and distract large
prey the head of SCP 1013 is distinctive
appearing to be that of a male chick on
first viewing however SCP 1013 does not
possess any standard Aven markers beside
these superficial resemblance the beak
is serrated and appears to possess very
basic needle-like teeth these are used
only in feeding and are not to be used
in any way to hunt prey the head also
lacks any feathers and has an enlarged
waddle SCP 103 Hunts by projecting a
form of unknown radiation wave or mtic
Force into pre items making eye contact
with SCP 1013 subjects report a sudden
stabbing pain in most major muscle
groups with full paralysis sending in
within 3 seconds this paralysis
continues for 8 minutes with full
recovery after 10 paralyzed subjects are
then bitten beginning the calcification
process Research into this effect is
ongoing as no form of Venom or viral
agents have been detected from this bite
however this contact will initiate a
rapid change in cellular structure in
the bitten subject the outer skin
tissues will begin a rapid calcification
growing very dense and inflexible over
several minutes this will extend from
the point of contact outward across the
body and can calcify human being in 15
minutes subjects recovering from
paralysis mid calcification report the
feeling as extremely painful with a
burning numbness in fully calcified
areas this calcification extends
approximately 3 cm into the body leaving
most internal tissues undisturbed
calcification does not appear to affect
the eyes mouth nose or other major
mucous membranes there is no currently
known way to reverse this process SCP
1013 will peck through the outer layer
of hardened flesh and begin to consume
tissues from the inside burrowing deep
into the body as flesh is consumed SCP
1013 has a voracious appetite and will
consume nearly twice its body weight at
each feeding SCP 1013 will only consume
living tissue and will ignore dead or
decomposing flesh SCP 1013 has been
noted to use natural body openings
primarily mouth and eyes when available
and is capable of compressing its body
to fit into very small openings prey
items often die from blood loss or
Massive Internal damage before feeding
is complete leaving the remainder of
tissues to decompose within the
calcified tissue this outer tissue will
slowly break down causing large sections
to crack and fall free this will expose
muscle and internal tissues which are
then often predated upon by SCP 1013 SCP
1013 will sometimes wait for this
process to begin before
feeding addendum recovery notes SCP
10113 was recovered in Egypt near a
former facil
due to this proximity and the lack of
additional SCP 10113 anywhere in the
surrounding area it is theorized that
SCP 1013 may be an engineered organism
SCP 1013 had calcified several animals
and two Shepherds and have been observed
on multiple occasions recovery was
achieved with only one death agent
proving much of our initial information
on the calcification process local
communities dismissed the incident with
no involvement from
Agents notes on Behavior SCP 1013 is
somewhat similar to a spider and will
paralyze and calcify subjects even when
not hungry presumably to keep them for
later this was observed during breach
incident 11h hour see attached
documentation when SCP 1013 calcified 20
members of Staff SCP 1013 is also very
aggressive and will attempt to stare
down and bite any subject that enters
the containment area the neck frill is
an amazing adaptation it lifts abruptly
with a loud snapping sound and often
times causes subjects to look directly
at SCP
1013 scp1 1013 seems to have a range of
about 54 M for its stair and appears to
need direct eye contact to work SCP 1013
appears to only paralyze one subject at
a time but can attack multiple subjects
in Rapid succession SCP 1013 appears to
be immune to its own stare reacting with
basic aggression to Reflections SCP 1013
feeds primarily on mammals attacking
animals such as fish birds or insects
only when near starving SCP 1013
exhibits a preference for soft tissues
eating the eyes and tongue first
whenever possible notes on reproduction
level two clearance required ongoing
testing into the feeding habits of SCP
1013 have been partially successful
questions were raised regarding the near
constant feeding exhibited by SCP 1013
which is highly irregular for a reptile
it was initially theorized that the
paralysis and calcification process were
metabolically taxing to SCP 1013
requiring enormous amounts of food to
fuel the process it is now apparent that
members of SCP 1013 are hrodi and appear
to reproduce in a way similar to budding
or basic cellular division SCP 1013 will
ingest massive amounts of tissue
increasing its body mass rapidly this
mass will then begin to form cystlike
structures in the tail section Each of
which contains a juvenile SCP 10113 the
process by which this occurs is
currently under investigation after 48
Hours juvenile SCP 1013 will forcibly
exit the parent body parent SCP 1013
will typically release spawn within C
ified prey juvenile SCP 1013 exhibit no
feeding preference and will consume any
biological material living or dead SCP
1013 do not engage in cannibalism and
will exit the calcified remains once
food has been exhausted juvenile SCP
1013 will seek out cool Dark Places and
begin rapid molting doubling in size
every 6 hours until reaching full adult
size new adult SCP 1013 will quickly
establish territories and begin the
feeding or spawning cycle again juvenile
SCP 1013 seek out areas such as
ventilation shafts Plumbing or discarded
clothing or shoes in which to Mt and
grow disturbing a juvenal during this
period will always provoke a sustained
attack this sequence of behavior was
discovered after a lockdown event in
site resulting from failure recovery
teams found the site to be infested with
SCP 1013 with over 1,000 individuals
being reported and destroyed final
sterilization took 8 weeks and resulted
in multiple staff deaths Research into
the control of the rampant reproductive
cycle with the goal of eventual
bioweapon designation is
ongoing this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
BP o crop guy the
Morgan James Saba Irish
wwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazaon worthy fire Dr Wolf
13 cubster Dean
denus that loser casadia cams braded
Peach jams Wright Rowan
O'Brien
kegn
grimnir extra moments
123 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
[Music]
you
for